Vegas now some people get lonely in
their love relationships right but some
people also get lonely and their work
relationships so here with advice on how
to love your work and your workspace is
Dana Bergeron with the coop co-work
space now you're a co-working space
expert yes right yes so explain it to
everyone what a co-working space is
exactly sure well a co-working space is
a shared office space with flexible
terms and we focus on community and
collaboration in our workspace and I
would say creativity there's always such
great creative stuff coming out of it it
really is that's the lovely thing about
a co-working space there's so many
different people in it so lots of
different ideas
definitely now what are the differences
you're seeing out there with people who
you would say love their job versus
people who for lack of a better word
hate their job well I think I think
what's important is to love where you
work right that's that that's becoming
more and more important now we're seeing
is to love where you work love how you
work love when you work so a co-working
space allows all of that to happen now
how would you or what advice would you
give someone who maybe doesn't know how
to connect with loving where they work
or who they're working with I would say
get to know the people around you a
little bit better wherever you're
working I think the uh the main thing to
focus on would be creating relationships
in your workspace no matter where you
work it's to uh you know seek that
camaraderie with other people once we
have a deeper connection with the people
we work with it makes us happier to be
there we look forward to being there
hearing about their stories and their
family these that's one of the many
benefits of of working in a shared
workspace I can personally relate to
that you know working with my Las Vegas
now team we're more than just co-workers
we're friends too and it really helps
the the camaraderie and the environment
yeah now how do you in your personal
life make work life more fun well my
work life I I kind of like to integrate
the two so I have friends who come into
the workspace I create events in the
workspace where both members of the
coupe and non-members can attend for
example tomorrow we have a single and
ready to mingle event happening
Valentine's Day coming up exactly so
it's it's for singles but it's also an
opportunity for people just to get
together and and to connect with one
another even in a workspace scenario too
I love when companies have you know
sports leagues with everybody Ted I know
we're we're trying to get that back
together but where can people find more
information about you sure well our
website site is the coopco work.com and
on all social media we are at the coop
co-work well thank you so much for
joining thank you so much for your
information great reminders everybody
work with people you love and you know
spread that Mercedes I'll send it to you
someone else I love to work with